suit en martinique pour deux raisons la
première c'est que il y a eu la
formation d'une loge samedi sport ce qui
prouve que les soeurs de martinique sont
des soeurs dynamique et
qui font donc rayonner notre obédience
et la deuxième raison c'est que je ne
je suis en martinique mais je suis passé
par la guyane je vais en guadeloupe et à
saint-martin pour rencontrer toutes les
soeurs de notre obédience
alors pourquoi les rencontrer car comme
toutes les obédiences nous organisons
des événements maçonnique
mais ces événements ont lieu en
métropole et à paris de ce fait très peu
de soeurs peuvent venir assister à ces
événements la sonic la relie à
l'éloignement bien entendu mais il ya
également le coût financier et donc j'ai
estimé que c'était respecter les soeurs
qui se déplaçait et respecter les soeurs
qui ne pouvaient pas venir assister à
ces événements devenir moi-même
accompagné d'une délégation est de
pouvoir rencontrer toutes les soeurs de
notre obédience qui sont aux antilles
guyane
il ya toujours un mystère autour de la
formation est pourquoi les ans maçon se
dévoile se présente est temps maintenant
je pense que
je suis pas sûr qu'il se dévoile plus
maintenant tabac en tout cas nous
restons toujours une
une société discrète alors se dévoile en
fait ceux qui ont envie de se dévoiler
quels sites atterries la loge féminine
de mai suisse misera yannick nous sommes
symboliques car nous estimons que le
symbole est un langage muet qui permet
de relier l'invisible par le visible
mais comme le nom l'indiqué nous sommes
égyptienne égyptienne de par
l'affiliation laurine de memphis misraïm
et le véhicule de certaines survivance
des anciens mystère ou d'égypte comment
avez vous retrouvé des loges de
mentonnais merveilleuse merveilleuse ce
sont des soeurs
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
dynamique chaleureuse
j'ai eu vraiment un accueil merveilleux
bien entendu fraternelle mais vraiment
d'une très grande
fraternité une très grande émotion et je
suis ravi
que les soeurs de martinique rayonne
pour notre obédience au sein de la
maçonnerie martiniquaise on parle
souvent de l'affluence des formations
sur une influence qu'en est il
réellement sur l'ensemble des problèmes
que rencontre la société alors les
sommes de la grande loge féminine de
memphis misraïm se définissent comme des
soeurs engager des femmes engagées
pardon alors nous sommes déjà engagés
par les serments qui nous lie à
l'intérieur de noël de nos loges mais
nous sommes également engagés dans la
cité alors en effet au cours de nos
travaux en loge nous n'abordons pas les
sujets sociétaux
mais beaucoup de seurre participent de
près ou de loin au sein d'associations
qui oeuvrent pour améliorer le quotidien
ou pour apporter un meilleur avenir à la
société civile et et part donc de ce
fait si vous voulez nous n'avons pas
d'implication
comment je dirais sa politique mais nous
avons une participation active dans la
cité la démarche initiatique est un
chemin qui nous ouvre les portes de la
spiritualité
donc c'est à dire qu'ils nous ouvrent
l'esprit sur ce qui lie à au delà de la
matérialité brut et je pense que le
monde actuel a besoin justement de cette
spiritualité sont les soeurs qui sont
sains d'autres ingrédients ce sont des
soeurs qui ont entamé cette démarche
commune à notre obédience et
donc je pense qu'elle adhère
complètement à cette notion et après
c'est à elle si vous voulez de voir dans
le paysage de leur île comment elles
peuvent diffuser et comment elles
peuvent interpeller les profanes qui
sont autour d'elle pour éventuellement
les faire rentrer dans nos ateliers